on s'attendait à une victoire facile les
ontariens ont finalement assisté à un
raz-de-marée conservateur
21h18 radio canada prévoit si la
tendance du vote ce médecin qui va faire
aura été rapide moins de 20 minutes
après la fermeture des bureaux de vote
d'eau crude était déjà donné victorieux
il majoritaire
[Applaudissements]
une victoire sismique qui n'a pas laissé
grand place aux partis d'opposition
le npd est arrivé deuxième avec 9 sièges
de moins qu'au déclenchement des
élections dans son fief de hamilton
andrea horvat s'est adressé à ses
militants émue elle a offert sa
démission après 13 ans à la tête du npd
et
les libéraux non plus n'ont pas réussi
leur pari avec seulement un siège de
plus qu'en 2018 une défaite cuisante qui
ne leur confère même pas le statut de
parti officiel par new line up leur chef
stephen del duca a aussi démissionné
après avoir été défait dans sa propre
circonscription
une élection qui risque de profondément
changé le paysage politique ontarien
pourtant ces résultats reflètent la
volonté d'une minorité de citoyens car
le taux de participation était anémique
43 % seulement un creux historique de
sofiane de l'autre
[Musique]
un message visiblement reçu par doc
froide ou lent mais l'élection le
premier ministre adopte un ton
rassembleur
avec une super majorité de 83 sièges sur
124 et deux partis d'opposition en
pleine reconstruction les conservateurs
devraient avoir les coudées franches
pour les quatre prochaines années avec
un taux de participation aussi faible
donc ford sait qu'il devra adapter son
style non s'il veut prouver qu'il est le
premier ministre de tous les ontariens
si les tirs est au canada toronto